Whoa! We're not quite done yet. This was the original end of
the class. And if you've made it this far and learned everything that
we've covered, you definitely accomplished a lot. And you've learned a lot
about computer science, as well as
Python programming. But we've learned that it's
very hard for students based on just this to be ready for
the next level of classes. So we added a few extra units that
I think will prepare you for that. As well as get you to
the next level as a programmer. The main focus of the extra units.
Is on how to mange complexity. This is something that becomes more
and more important as your programs get longer and more complicated. As well
as if you start working in teams to build larger programs. Where you
have to understand other peoples code, and they have to understand your code.
As you develop as a programmer, learning how to mange complexity becomes
more and more important, and these new units will teach you tools and
techniques for how to do that. I congratulate you on getting to the
end of the original course, but hope you'll stick with it, and join
me for the new units.